so how did Steve Jobs fit into this
whole equation well we originally met
Stevie he 20 visit us at at Pixar and at
that time we were starting this process
of thinking about spinning out and then
Steve disappeared and then we repaired
several months later after we'd started
to talk a lot of other companies and he
of course had been kicked out of Apple
so when he first met with us he wanted
to buy us out to turn us into the
computer company he wanted to make and
what we said was well actually our dream
is to make an animated film so we
declined and then Steve went off and
formed next computer and then after he
formed next we ran into each other
because the computer graphics conference
that year was fortunately in San
Francisco and so Steve came by our booth
and our negotiations were all going to
hell with these other places and we were
in danger of being just stop and
shutdown and I'll let go so we started
up the the talks with Steve and he was
now interested in acquiring Pixar but on
the terms of what we wanted to do and so
we went through this actually one of the
hardest negotiation to ever been through
my life but we were acquired for five
million dollars from Lucasfilm and then
he and you're worth more than that now
right 70 million dollars just from the
two days who might not know but that was
1986 dollars so you know yeah so at that
time it wasn't even at all practical to
make an animated film so we have this
long term vision but we're smart enough
to know that we're nowhere near it so we
start to sell hardware you have to
understand everybody at this point in
time in order to do computer animation
there was no off-the-shelf software and
computers were very big very expensive
and you needed machine rooms to run them
you know the the personal computer was
just a very kind of small you know a
small not very powerful thing
and and so in order to do computer
animation you had to write your own
software build everything from scratch
also in our case in all the things that
that the Lucas own computer division was
developing we had to invent our own
hardware and that's where so the the a
big portion of the the Lucas own
computer division and then Pixar in the
early days was hardware and software
designers and the Pixar image computer
was was so far ahead of its time it was
it was starting to be used in medical
imaging in fact Pixar first did the
first 3d reconstruction of cat and mr
scans which is very commonplace now but
it was invented at Pixar we did a lot of
a seismic thing we were mean that some
of the people got CIA clearances because
they they had we realized that there was
out there in the world there was a lot
of high resolution kind of data
gathering devices from cameras
satellites seismic MRR scans and all
like that but there was no such thing as
high definition yet or any any kind of
computer to use it and that's what this
computer was and it was so far ahead of
its time that there was absolutely no
customers for it at all except a few
wait we have the medical customers and
the other one was it turns out that when
there was a hostile takeover of Disney
by Roy Disney jr. and the bass brothers
one of the things that Roy Disney jr.
wanted to do was to bring energy back
into animation which that point was in
pretty bad shape so it was Roy who who
led them to enter into a contract for us
to write the software to color of the
cells using our Pixar image computer and
that was the start of our formal
business relationship with Disney driven
by Roy Disney and so we started with
with yeah Roy was a visionary